[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
uh
i don't think there's a single
definition of privacy
i think it captures a whole
cluster of related problems that have to
do with
information these days a lot but also
kind of control
over our lives as they relate to
others and our relationships the kind of
different layers we like to have
in our lives in my
research i focus a lot on sort of a
certain class of problems which
have to do with how
we can publish useful aggregate
level information about data sets
without
leaking too much about individuals who
are in those data sets
privacy is important because it
gets at a lot of the
notions of freedom that we think are
fundamental
in modern society freedom of speech
freedom of association
freedom of religion if
you're in a situation where you're
constantly being monitored
you live your life differently
and sometimes that can be a
good thing for example we uh
we insist on on public scrutiny
of politicians actions and
at least the actions they take publicly
and the things they say publicly
but very often that kind of scrutiny
causes a chilling effect
of stopping people from speaking their
minds
you know even very simply if i want to
have a difficult conversation with
somebody i'd very often rather do it in
a quiet room without
32 other people listening than out in
the middle of a
you know a of a in a public space or in
a lounge space where all their
colleagues are nearby
right or if i want to have even with my
kids you know if i want to have a
difficult conversation with one of them
about
you know some horrible thing they did to
their sibling
yeah it works much better if i can get
them out of the
out of the uh away from the attention of
their siblings where they
they feel comfortable opening up where
they're not sort of
so defensive if we think
our words are going to be used against
us we speak differently
and in a society where we value
uh people experimenting with ideas and
and being critical of power in all of
its various forms then we have to
provide that kind of
space where people can can think and act
freely
and where um people's actions at one
point in their life don't necessarily
follow them around their whole lives
so as a statistician we actually
have a i think slightly different
perspective on privacy
um for us it really is confidentiality
that we worry about because
in order to produce statistics we always
need information from people
so not getting any information
and keeping everything private is not
even something we
think about but what we worry about a
lot is to make sure that
the information we get stays
confidential
with the person or the entity or the
researcher who collects the data
and only
let's say in the past aggregate
statistics have been released and so
um that that for us is the main concern
how can we keep the confidentiality that
a respondent or data subject
provided in us you know being willing to
share information
privacy is appropriate flow of
information
end of story my name is adam smith i'm a
professor of computer science at
boston university and i work on
data privacy cryptography information
theory and a bunch of
topics that revolve around those themes
helen nissenbaum professor at cornell
tech in
information science and director of the
digital life initiative
yeah so my name is franco croiter i'm a
director and professor at the university
of maryland we have a program there in
survey methodology that i run
and i also hold a professor appointment
at the university of manheim in germany
with the department of social science
there
which you know technically is only half
a point in the other half is
at the institute for employment research
in nuremberg
which is kind of good for me here in
this context because i do get the
government perspective and the academic
perspectives in
one appointment for me the most exciting
not not i shouldn't say the most
exciting but a very exciting
element of being here at simon's was to
have the chance to work with hell
nissenbaum i think that
her strong push for us to think of
privacy
in context is is
groundbreaking and a very important
shift in the discussion because i think
does matter and you know
where and for which purpose data is used
and it is much easier to discuss
and think through data in the context of
a purpose and a particular usage
than it is globally i think we we just
get stuck if we try to solve this
globally and so
um so i think this combination of you
know thinking of innovative technology
but in context and for a particular
context
really could push us forward it's a
little bit of a thing
actually because there are many people
who will say there isn't a single
definition of privacy privacy is a very
complicated
chaotic concept and it is true that
many people use privacy in different
ways
but i've for the past many years since
developing the theory of contextual
integrity i've urged
a very simple definition which is
appropriate flow of information
and then i've allowed for people
including myself
to offer a definition of what
appropriate flow of information is
but even if you take that first step
along with me
it's it means something because we're
admitting
that what's valuable about privacy isn't
that
information stops flowing but that
it flows appropriately and then from
then
after that one can then
propose what one believes to be
appropriate flow
and that's when the theory of contextual
integrity comes
into play a century ago or two centuries
ago when people lived in
sort of generally smaller tighter
communities
people had less privacy in some sense
than they knew do now because
you know it was it was a village and
everybody knew each other and everybody
knew things about each other
um we've as we've moved into
uh modern life our
sense of what privacy we can have
and and should have has changed of
course um
and we're we're coming back to a setting
where
maybe or maybe we're coming back to a
setting
where we'll have
it'll be harder to limit what's known
about us the big difference is that
you know in a village you're you're
sharing information with people
you know and poss maybe trust but it's
there's a symmetry to the situation
whereas
the big thing that's changed in in
modern life is the the fact that
um now the organ the institutions and
organizations and you know
i hesitate to say people but systems
that know things about us
are are these kind of large large
companies like google
governments organizations and so there
isn't
and there isn't any kind of symmetry and
i think this is one of the
things that people are really grappling
with
right now and just don't have we don't
have
really good a good handle on how to
where we want society to go
is how do we give individuals
some kind of agency over how
how they define the different spheres of
their lives and how they limit
others access to those fears this topic
that we have now
around privacy and the use of data in
society for societal goods
is very dear to my heart because i do
think
there is a lot of value in data but we
need to make sure it's good
do you know because otherwise the wrong
conclusions will be drawn out of it and
it's only the
i mean it's not the data per se we're
interested in it's the information
we derive out of it and a lot can go
wrong in that process
well i want to differentiate
between information flowing in
appropriate ways
and information not flowing which is a
popular definition
of privacy often it's the definition of
privacy that people in the technical
community
computer scientists subscribe to and the
reason
i push back against that is that
i want privacy to have moral
to carry moral weight and if we
say that privacy is about secrecy
or it's about stopping information flow
just stopping it
then we all know that
just stopping information isn't can't
always be defended
and it isn't even good for society
because so much good stuff happens in
society because we share
information and we know that some
stoppage of
information flow some uses of secrecy
are counterproductive and they and they
work against
social good and so i would rather have
privacy
carry moral weight and then figure out
what is an isn't appropriate flow
i believe there is a right to privacy
not however if we define
privacy as secrecy because i can't
defend
a right to secrecy but if we consider
privacy to be appropriate flow
then i do believe there's a right to
privacy but that's
the right an individual has to privacy i
also in my own work am more interested
in defending
privacy as a value for society
just in the same way as we say justice
is a value to which society
subscribes i want to say that privacy is
a value
to which society subscribes because i
strongly believe that privacy
promotes societal good
if you if you limit the focus of
privacy benefits to the interests of the
individual
you'll only have part of the story of
why privacy is
important and why we should have strong
ways of
protecting promoting defending privacy
and that's part of what again this is
part of
what i develop in the theory of
contextual integrity is to
explore and explain the societal
value of privacy
the theory of contextual integrity
presents a
vision of society as
constituted by a range of societal
contexts or domains
it's not the contextual integrity
doesn't
doesn't put forward that theory of
society rather it
it it casts about and it's clear that
there are many social theories who adopt
that
that adopt that framing so the reason
i've stuck with contextual integrity
is because i want to show how
the rules or the norms that we live by
that that prom that
prescribe different flows of information
are important for promoting the ends
of these different societal contexts and
it'll it's probably easier to
say that with an example
so if we think about the educational
context or we may think about the
healthcare context
what are the aims of those different
contexts
now that in itself is controversial
it may be that not everyone in society
would agree
on what the aims of healthcare are or
what the aims of the educational
context are but given that there's
certain ends and purposes that these
social domains serve to promote
contextual integrity argues
that the flows of information the rules
that govern information flows in those
contexts are legitimate
insofar as they promote those ends and
they're problematic
in so insofar as they don't so if you
consider something like healthcare
perhaps several centuries ago the
hippocratic oath might have said
a physician shouldn't speak at all
of what he finds in a household
where this someone ill today
this we know a lot more about health
care so we may
say it's fine for the physician
to share information with public health
authorities
let's say if someone has
gastric upset
and they've eaten at a local restaurant
or some such
because that promotes health
of of society in general
but if physicians had
no confidentiality requirements
then individuals might not want to share
any information about themselves because
they're afraid of embarrassment
losing a job and so on and so if you're
ill
you may not even want to visit a
physician or you may go from one
physician to the next
you may refuse certain important tests
and that would
be bad for you but it would also be bad
for society
because of what we know about say
contagious diseases
and so these these rules we have about
information flow
which are privacy rules
are carefully calibrate calibrated in
many instances
to promote the ends and purposes of
context
that's really the fundamental part
of contextual integrity so when we
started having those waves like the
early waves rfid
surveillance cameras databases which was
even in the 60s and the 70s
people were freaking out 1984
brave new world and the argument of
contextual integrity
is that they're freaking out because
data is moving in an unexpected way
it's moving inappropriately and that was
because we had these
norms of how it should be flowing
but experts understand
that when you reveal information
of a certain kind in fact you're
revealing you actually
revealing a whole lot and so even though
you're quite happy with this
society needs to regulate to the
realities of it
and inform people that this
is legitimate
and so contextual integrity has
actual expectation of flow and then
legitimate
flow and the legitimacy of the flow
has to be keyed to the extent possible
to the reality
and the computer scientists and
colleagues of mine here and colleagues
of mine
at cornell tech we unders they
you know that they understand that
sometimes
there's a complete disconnect between
those two things
and it was clear to me when i started
thinking about
all the different fields of information
that we might say
are not sensitive it's
i challenged myself to saying i can't
think of a single piece of information
about which there isn't at least
some rule and that's how i came up with
this
use case if you will that even your name
if you're walking down the street and a
stranger confronts you and asks you your
name
you're quite well within your rights to
say none of your business
and that just triggered me to saying if
there isn't
any kind of information about which
anything goes
then privacy is about something else
so to begin there's there's a
there's a great opportunity for people
like myself who are philosophers and
also social scientists
to collaborate with computer scientists
of all sorts of different
types so on the side of of encryption
and theoretical computer science but
then also
people who design systems and
and enforce enforce certain flows
when when i say that privacy is not the
same as secrecy
i use the term secret to mean
here's some information about me nobody
else should know that information
what contextual integrity in saying
appropriate flow
that still may mean that appropriate
flow may
require consent from me sometimes
it may require sharing with this party
under those conditions and not with that
party under
different conditions and different types
of information
and in and in the grand idea of privacy
by design
in order to enforce these
fine-grained different constraints in a
system
you really need to bring to bear the
most sophisticated thinking
about encryption and and zero not you
know all of those things can
be brought into the implementation and
enforcement
of these norms within a system in my
research
i'm interested in uh mostly on
a specific question
which is how we can use these
enormous data sets that are collected
everywhere by
in tons of different contexts
to you know get useful information out
of them get the benefits of having these
huge data sets
while ensuring that the you know
individuals are not
harmed by by these uses that that
individual
in the information that people think of
as sensitive doesn't
isn't easily suddenly made easily
accessible by
the these publications so imagine you
know a few
few kinds of questions that i'm
interested in for example
if i tell you uh how many
how many kids go to a particular school
that on its own doesn't seem to tell me
much about
those kids but now once i start breaking
it down
by where those kids live
by ethnicity by
you know whether or not they're citizens
where they were born
how they did on different kinds of tests
what kinds of psychological problems
they have
whether or not they need help paying for
lunch suddenly i get
this very detailed picture of the
individual
families and children that are at this
school
and so one of the sort of scientific
questions there is
how do we make
that information available in a form
that's still useful
but somehow that we we have an assurance
that we're not
telling you all about you know this
particular kid or this particular family
and you know i think a lot of people
adults find this
kind of hits home when we start talking
about things like
uh tax records or medical records
uh or in general whatever it is about
their lives that they're not
so comfortable discussing with the whole
world
so the kind of data sets that
i'm interested in studying
come from a range of different domains
but just to give you some examples that
that are good to keep in mind
uh think of uh government
uh data sets that are collected for all
sorts of reasons you know tax records
are
an example that
that are very detailed and the
government has a good reason to collect
and very you know to maintain those very
well
things like census data things like
data collected by the cdc
epidemiological data
the other kind of data set that we think
a lot about is
what's collected in the the data centers
of companies like google
and amazon microsoft
apple linkedin you name it all of them
collect very detailed records about
their users
they do this for lots of different
reasons
one of the stated reasons is to provide
the best experience for their
customers that they can
and then other reasons is because that
that data itself is valuable to them
to they they use it to sell advertising
or they just sell the data itself
whatever that is
i got into privacy because
i saw it as an area that was important
that was
changing very quickly this is in the
early 2000s when i was in graduate
school
and where we had essentially no formal
or mathematical
handle on what the problem was or how to
think about it
and i it's not that i think that um
formalism is important it's in its own
right
but what i what that sort of what
mathematical what mathematics gives us
is a language for speaking precisely
about things
and that was exactly what was missing in
uh the work on statistical privacy
uh in the early 2000s and so i started
working
i was actually an intern at microsoft
research with cynthia dwork
and we spent a bunch of time
bouncing around ideas of what is this
this broad question about leakage in
public statistics
what does it actually mean what do you
know what are we trying to prevent what
are we trying to achieve
developing a mathematical formalism for
privacy
is important because well for for a
bunch of different reasons
maybe first and foremost is it gives us
a language for
thinking about a problem it gives us
um a number of tools to
[Music]
to speak quantitatively about you know
a problem in this case you know the
things i'm interested in we're trying to
quantify information leakage and how
much
information is learned or how much is
learned um
but in general it
it's important for a field in in um as a
whole because it
it pushes people to make statements that
are
that actually can be wrong right the the
advantage of precision
is and and sort of that sort of clear
logical formalism
is that it it allows people to make
refutable statements it allows people in
some cases to prove statements in an
ironclad way
and that'll that gives us a clear
understanding of assumptions
but but even just providing the language
to make statements that are actually
wrong is you know counter-intuitively a
huge advance
right because if you can prove someone
wrong then you can move the discussion
forward if
the statements are being made are too
hand-wavy to um
to to conclusively contradict
then you wind up in this kind of murky
uh back and forth with where it's hard
to make progress
i think one of the important
questions for computer science and
and you know academics in a bunch of
different fields
is what exactly could
our society look like and how do we how
do we
create the tools that will allow you
know
us broadly as a society to to choose the
version we
you know the version of the future we
actually want to live in
right it's easy in a capitalist society
to be
sort of pulled along the path of least
resistance as
defined by you know largest profits
but the question is can you know are
there other
tools we should be developing other ways
of doing things for example can we
can we get all the benefits of
you know maps applications without
having google and apple you know collect
all information about
everywhere we go can we get personalized
um even personalized advertising without
necessarily
directly sharing our information with
the systems that place the
advertisements
so we as statisticians or i'm as a
server methodologist we collect data
often for to inform government policy
decisions
down the road i mean we have primary i
mean statistical officers
are in charge of
using numbers to describe the current
state of the population how is the
health how is the education how
is the wealth distribution and they
often shy away from
actual decision-making but they provide
that piece of information
a good example where it's difficult to
get
currently difficult to get good numbers
is the
the state of immunization in the
population
right parents go with the kids to a
doctor's office and
may or may not have them immunized but
um with not in the absence of a
centralized
medical record system in which all that
data can flow together um
you know a country might be interested
in knowing what
the rate of vaccination is um
in in the population and so
traditionally at least in the us
one way to do that would be to draw a
random sample from the population call
the parents
and ask them about the vaccination of
their children
now with the caveat they might sometimes
forget sometimes they even forget the
like
the third child they have or what have
you but that's the idea that
in increasingly i would say we use
multiple sources so it could be
in part medical records in part surveys
and interviews where we ask people
directly
but all of this of course is shared in
confidence
with the assumption that it stays with
for is used for that particular purpose
that
we ask the data
most of the surveys in the us are
voluntary
and um people have a choice but as we
discussed and read many times this
decision on whether you participate or
not might be one on the fly
and not well grounded in good reasoning
some data collections are mandatory the
census is a good example
we have to count everybody in the u.s
and therefore
you're obliged to participate
and some other surveys are too and you
could see a world and i think
it's a societal debate we need to have
is how much of the data we produce on a
day-to-day basis
can or should stay with you and how much
of it would you need to share in order
to make the society better
one could certainly argue that in the
last decade
the data that i created through everyday
life outstripped our ability to
deal with it and and i i think
there's a lot to that more in the sense
is that
a lot of devices are collecting data and
relieving traces and records in places
where
that's probably unnecessary to perform a
function
and you know if you will if you if you
think of an app that's built
you know there are lots of choices you
have to make you know what
data to collect or not and you could you
could require excess or you could you
know keep something
or not and and i'm i'm sure not every
engineer is sort of thinking through the
whole process
on you know every piece of data what's
it useful do we really need it and what
have you
the opposite might be true true that in
other areas of life we are not
collecting enough
information right but i think
right now a lot is driven what can be
done and then it will be done for a
while
right rather than having a concept on
what are the pieces of information we
need and then we reduce
the data collection to that um i'm not
surprised
anytime technology develops fast that's
what happens
but i do think that um that this con
it's not too late to have that
conversation you know i think
in certain places we can dial back and
and i feel like this
style discussion is happening around
that you know it's like what is it that
we really need
in order to provide functions both
for the private sector side as well as
the government side
so there are almost no limits on how
these you know vast collections of data
we now have
could be used and they're just lots and
lots of ways in which they can benefit
society
what we as computer scientists will
often do is
say well let's say i want to allow for a
certain
a certain use of the data or maybe a
certain category of uses
what's the best way i can do that and
how do i
you know to what extent is it necessary
to provide information
in order to uh in order
to enable that use right if i want to
have a conversation with my physician i
really
i really need them to see my information
if i want to have a face-to-face
conversation with my physician
but if i'm trying to build if i'm a
hospital trying to build a system that
will
help physicians figure out if there are
enough patients to run a particular kind
of study
then uh then it's not clear that that
they need like the kind of
that that system needs fine grain access
to my information
so differential privacy arose from
the kind of question we were just
discussing how do we
enable various kinds of you know
aggregate uses without leaking
information
and what we wanted was a
kind of a definition a way to restrict
the
algorithms that process the information
such that any algorithm that satisfies
this restriction
will be acceptable
for in terms of confidentiality
and and then subject that restriction we
can try to design the best possible
algorithms for various tasks and
that's a lot of the research on
differential privacy is sort of
centered around that type of question
all right
the way that differential privacy
restricts the algorithm
is it considered it considers a thought
experiment
in this thought experiment we imagine
what would happen
if my data were somehow completely
changed in the data set
say one person's data let's say mine
they might be removed
they might be added they might just be
changed to the data of a totally
different person
and what we'd like to say is that from
the point of view of an outside observer
these this thought experiment is
indistinguishable
from the real situation where the real
data set is used
and so that means that for all
intents and purposes
the system behaves the same whether or
not
my data are are actually used
where it behaves almost the same and the
almost part is where the sort of where
the science comes in and the math comes
in is we're trying to quantify that
almost in
you know tight away as we can but
at least intuitively the guaran what it
guarantees is that
each one of us individually has the
assurance that whatever comes out of the
system
and whatever's learned about the world
from the system
won't be too specific to me and what
what is the other probability
distribution that one gets
in this thought experiment where one
person's data
are completely changed
we look at the difference between those
probability distributions
we quantify that difference with a
parameter usually denoted
epsilon and that parameter
measures in a in a very direct sense it
measures the
the difference between this thought
experiment and the and the real world
but it also what we also understand is
it it
has various implications about
the types of reasoning you can do about
me
based on the outputs of the system so
what we can prove
mathematically is that when this epsilon
quantity
is not too big then the conclusions you
draw about me
are going to be the same up to this
epsilon
whether or not my data were in the data
set
or not
so this quantity epsilon gives us
one quantification of how much is leaped
and so if i look at the
paradigmatic cases that differential
privacy
practitioners or
theorists are working on they're looking
at cases
of providing public access so that's
a form of information flow to
data to large-scale data in particular
but
to data in a way in in a way that
doesn't violate
norms so like i'm trying to
take what they're trying to do and
express it in the language of contextual
integrity
so it may be that
the information that's flowing to
to a third party
we we don't we we want to avoid
having that information um
having that third party know that the
information is about
a particular individual that it's that
the the information that this person
has liver cancer
is information about
jane so we want to avoid that because
that would be
inappropriate flow and so we see
differential privacy as a weight as a
mechanism
for preventing inappropriate flow so at
that at a superficial level
that's how i would start to connect
those things
so it's natural to ask what this epsilon
really tells us what we know is that the
smaller epsilon is
the more ironclad a guarantee we're
getting
um the larger epsilon is the
weaker a guarantee we're getting and as
epsilon once epsilon is very very large
then
there's a sense in which the i mean
there's the guarantee at some point
becomes
just vacuous i mean it doesn't really
tell you anything at all
uh and in the in the limit where epsilon
is really big you could just
you know you could just publish the data
in raw form and that would
you know satisfy the definition but just
with an outrageously huge value of
epsilon
it's important to remember that
differential privacy
is not a black or white standard it's a
measure really
of kind of the degree of protection
provided by a particular system
and um that means that anytime someone
makes a claim that they're doing things
differently privately
the people who are thinking about
whether or not this system is acceptable
if they whoever those people are the
broad public or auditors
more likely um
it uh it's important for them to
understand
what kinds of parameters the system is
really providing
right so as with
any technology uh you know
it can be used to sort of whitewash
various problems and
and so uh one has to be a kind of a
skeptical consumer of the science and of
the
of the claims made by um companies just
as with
as with anything else and maybe a good
good analogy is something like
encryption
you know just because companies use
encryption doesn't mean they're using it
well or
uh using the most modern standards or
encrypting the right things you know the
the details uh i mean they're not just
details i guess
the exact way in which it's uh in which
it's used really matter a lot
what i experienced here at simon's is
that computer scientists
think about privacy quite differently
than statisticians do
what was novel to me was sort of this
very large concept of like a general
threat
to prevent against anything possibly
happen with the data
and to find solution that have sort of
this
the the to find solution that are more
global
that that can can allow a data used
broadly
without any risk
as statisticians i think we we
traditionally think more in confined
data sets that sit somewhere and can be
used in some way
and and i think um
both disciplines have to learn a little
bit from each other
for one you know we know about big data
we know
lots of large databases are there
working with such data is very different
to begin with and many of the solutions
that differential privacy provides
are actually much more
easily implementable when you interact
with the big database
than when you have a data set on your
computer that you're trying to work with
and so i think that that we as
statisticians have to learn
to interact with databases in a way that
we haven't done so in the past
um it's also interesting to me that
and i'm not sure if we would call that
privacy
but it is interesting to me that for
the solutions that the computer
scientists think of
when noise is added to the data that
the no information no true information
about me is leaked
right so let's say my income is not
longer
50 000 but 55 000 right then no true
information is leaked
but i think that for social scientists
they may or may not think that is
a helpful solution because
there's still information there that
gets associated with me
and now it's wrong information maybe
that's even more uncomfortable for to a
particular person right
or take the extreme if you think we want
to prevent a
re-identification attack or
reconstruction attack on the census data
so that you cannot let's say the
citizenship
question were on the census that you
cannot find
out who is a citizen and who isn't
or that you can't know whether that
label citizen or nazism is correct or
not
but you could imagine someone who is a
citizen not wanting
the non-citizen label accidentally be
attached
to their name right and i think these
are aspects social
science aspects of these privacy
solutions that
are not necessarily on the radar of
computer scientists so at least they
don't talk about that as much
one of the things about being a
philosopher and working
in the space of privacy and generally
digital technology
and ethics is that you
can either remain at the level of
abstraction
and work in in concepts and theories and
never really
um connect with what's going on
in the world but it was
always exciting to me to work across
disciplinary lines i've
i've really loved working with computer
scientists
and why it's fabulous being
here at simon's and working amongst
computer scientists sometimes it's
frustrating
because we do have
a language gap but i guess the important
thing is to try and
narrow that gap and also to realize that
some because of the theory of contextual
integrity which talks about
entrenched social norms that the reason
people freak out when something happens
you know the latest shenanigans of this
or that company with their data
as not necessarily because
of the fact that any information is
flowed but it's flowed inappropriately
but unders what we mean by
appropriateness
is that is that we have expectations
and those expectations are because
there's certain
norms that exist in society there's
certain behavioral expectations
so it's really necessary
if i want to argue that contextual
integrity is a good theory
to be able to do empirical research
with people and learn
about the norms themselves if i
you know if the theory is claiming that
there are these norms and people freak
out when
when companies or governments violate
these norms
then it's my responsibility to try and
demonstrate that these norms
actually exist i don't know i can't say
for sure what exactly the norms are
but we need to study what those
expectations are for one thing
judges sit in courts and have to
determine
whether a certain action or practice
violates
reasonable expectation of privacy and
they've just been making that up
here we're trying to show rigorously
what those norms are
and so i've been fortunate to
collaborate with people who
have familiarity with social scientific
research methodologies where we can go
out and
survey hundreds thousands of people
to question them on some of those norms
and expectations
so some of the empirical work is
actually
asking questions about privacy
expectations
utilizing the contextual integrity norm
structure
and providing some knowledge to the
world about what the expectations are
and then some of the empirical work is
also for example
a recent study looking at privacy
policies
where we've shown given at least
one reason why people it's impossible
for even a very expert person
to read a privacy policy and know what
it means because when you
analyze that empirically you find that
any given privacy policy can amount to
a thousand statements of what the
information flow structures
are what um differential privacy does
is it tells us just you know how by how
much do we have to kind of
mess with the parameters of the model in
order to
have a provable guarantee that these
types of inference attacks are not
possible
it also tells us various interesting
structural things that
you know as one might expect the richer
the model we want to set
and the richer the model we want to fit
the harder it gets and the
possibly the more noise we have to add
and that very much corresponds to
what we understand about when these
attacks work which is the more complex
the model
the easier it is to design attacks
this is becoming especially important
now that you know regression is
a nice simple model but people are
fitting much more complex machine
learning models to data sets
and we have a much worse understanding
of
exactly what those models
tell and capture about the data set we
have a number of examples
where they actually sort of memorize
individual data points or
memorize specific features of individual
data points
and so doing things with a guarantee
like differential privacy
gives us the sort of peace of mind that
we we actually have a complete picture
of what's being
leaked or or not leaked by the release
of a particular model
and there's this whole line of research
on
developing and thinking through what
sorts of
you know attacks on privacy are possible
and by an attack here
what exactly an attack means can vary
from situation to situation but it might
mean
you know suppose i go in knowing
something about
a particular person let's say adam i
could you know can i figure out if atom
is the in the data set that would be a
very simple kind of attack
or maybe i go in knowing some partial
information about
you know this person adam maybe i can
reconstruct the rest of their record
or even in the most extreme versions
maybe i go in knowing nothing at all
and somehow from the output of the
system i can just reconstruct the entire
data set
and actually those are called
reconstruction attacks because they
reconstruct the data set
and um interestingly people at the
census
recently conducted this type of attack
on their own
releases in a sort of internal
experiment that has been discussed in
public
where they were able to
[Music]
reconstruct the version of
decennial census data so this is the
main census that the census does every
10 years
they were able to reconstruct the
supposedly confidential version
of that data set from uh
information that was published at the
time of the last census
one thing that i always found surprising
when talking to
theorists or people who are not involved
in data collection
that data sort of exists and then you
work on a solution
with the existing data but often
what's forgotten is to think about all
the steps in the data generating process
someone deciding to even participate in
a survey
someone deciding to turn off the phone
so that no data is transmitted and
and and if you want to have
good data you need to be aware of
the pieces where the data collection
process breaks down
and you need to fix those
pieces i'm not sure
if the technical solutions to privacy
that are discussed right now
differential privacy would help with
these problems because these problems
might have to do with trust
these problems might have to do with
understanding
and um and i mean if you if you take
a different view of the world where we
would all a society says like yes
our data is needed for a government to
make good decisions
then then this issue of safeguarding
maybe might look very differently right
so the privacy paradox that people love
to
call a paradox and i don't think it's a
paradox at all
is the observation that on the one hand
survey after survey in survey after
survey
people will say they care about privacy
privacy is very important and yet when
we observe the behaviors
they seem not to care so they'll share
information on
facebook and uh the standard joke is
they'll they'll sell their privacy for
for a cup of coffee
and so forth and that's and that's the
privacy paradox
well there are many reasons why i and
others in the privacy community have
rejected the concept of a paradox
one of the reasons by the way let me say
why it's important
to scrutinize that claim one of the
reasons it's
popular among the collectors of
information who would like not to be
regulated
is they say oh people say this but
actually they don't really care
let us do whatever we want to do and not
bother us
we have quite a number of
systematic reasons why what seems like a
paradox isn't
from the point of view of contextual
integrity
one of the arguments and now we've just
we're just about to publish a third
study in this
line of studies one of our arguments is
when surveys ask people
questions about their opinions
or their attitudes to privacy they're
not asking the survey
correctly they're not asking the
questions correctly
they're not they're failing to mention
some of the key parameters
and so the responses that they're
getting from people are ambiguous
so if it's about sharing information
period without saying with whom
you don't know what people are thinking
what the paradigmatic
sharing instance is so it turns out that
people
really don't like the information
flowing to data brokers
but they don't mind information about
say their location
flowing to emergency responders
they think that's quite fine so
so one of the problems is how the
surveys
have tried to elicit people's attitudes
to privacy
secondly when asked about
when when people are are in fact
sharing information say on facebook
until quite recently when there was so
much
of facebook in the news people were much
much more preoccupied about
the sharing across the platform their
friends and so forth
and once they started understanding
these different flows
they they started freaking out
but just the fact that you care about
privacy
again doesn't mean that you're object to
sharing information with your friends
the reason i remain fixated on
these the set of questions surrounding
privacy
is that whether whether willfully
or not there's a
there's an ignorance surrounding
what privacy is and why it's important
that makes me worried that we're walking
down a trajectory
where we may get to a point where
we're not protecting privacy at all and
for me
it's going to be the extinguishing
of social institutions i'm not
i mean i am of course worried about harm
to individuals
but what the the
you could say the unhappy affirmation
if you will of some of my fears with the
cambridge analytica
case was that the lack of respect for
privacy
can go a long way to distinct to
extinguishing democracy
coming back to haunt us is this
conception of privacy as
the requirement of consent that feels so
retrograde as long as we're going down
that path
i'm quite pessimistic
you